[Music]
Frankie oh my god I am so sorry Frankie
stop but you know he's a friend what a
terrible terrible way to mean
your lieutenant McKenna Mary I am
Victoria leaves the new owner of course
I know exactly who you are
well welcome to Emerald Bay thank you so
much
I heard you a head-turner what an
understatement that is okay and I heard
you were a child
I guess that's an understatement
um I apologize for thank you I know this
Beach is public and honestly I wish the
tub was to with you you're welcome
anytime thank you very much that's will
[ __ ] hold up check this out excuse me
it's a very nice scooter you ever seen
the Olympics
what are you having some time why the
[ __ ] you drivers will stay off the grass
it's presently fertilized watch it shut
up you're beautiful border collie right
down respect up some respect mommy's a
baby mommy's a baby's here
go get him Stan a pathway you get the
white one all right you're just slow me
down anyway
Oh
[Music]
[Music]